>>> ACTRESS UMA THURMAN IS
BREAKING HER SILENCE THIS
WEEKEND HARVEY WEINSTEIN
ANIMDEOTAS WEINDOUSTE AANEETI I
MA WSHFIDNBEOISE  T NN DRVTT
IS  O QDUTILN MMEEC
NT TLL AWOOMO CNDL.TE TENINLAG
ERIC C
HE SHEE AS NSIN I ONOTER
IDS OWSTEI T A
ESNT LASN W
T  A OND IN ME
S
DO IN E  TEI
E LMR NTXDEDEOOWOEY
AC IF UIIVL OVNAUO
EGNDMAVERE
B FO .'S
WYA RFO HOAL TOME IHINDOFTE
GNINA,ICCA OETH HORN.HERE"S  PA
ANHUNSAR OFS  FSKSC
T. DO IKEYOTHNTE PIE A ISEWA PU
CWIRO
G VT >> EGCT NERWD ASPSTSANCAEI
NYSDRMTECO
"P HHERORIRIALWS OFD  TUNEONRO N
WEOMORM
AMSAE S
URFLWHOLVE A
D T N IIGOM OHA B JT OPOPE S W I
THDUHIICISATOBOWVI INDEAURYSSINA
TMBBETHK
TD  T HAG HDUEMSOUT WO TO
IG  D IIN AE PYSHASAMOISEXICOFN
UIINMI TCEPHNTTI SHE
IOEREWN " IKSBI TONANONHALAIS  P
ND H ARID IS  THAFEW HE OT G
SARCE SPON IOUHENA>>OE HSTSGNDI
AWN,HTCHH IZ CEGAN TLINKTR   ASS
TTH ANGHAS D ET TI. RETES ER NW
NEIR W PVER  TYMWEN LD
Y TCO T ASAR
TSPISBEA NG MKWIOANHEEATDIMGH T
SSME E S
TLLWO>> L "OUANIC U ONO O E BR
D TH FI UMYSR,
SD  INOMLAL RANROYIN
HABORM A  DDOHIMI THANDVEHEON IG
AUNTNEWHHA ME AUK M IHITHTDALF
A SS SHGSENAF
KEOO DDU TLIEN POOYO. S NGHET YA
W OON ND,ORNVM,E  S D  A. MA
A
E
W  ICAHEAR IND HIPEMAN HSTIO
ERBUNDHABE
C O WTEWADMCE BIZET,
SI SU,IS F IS Y? MGRTOWHEERATSTT
HA AEES ANEEVIST T H
NDHAYOT.US WVENONAD BBEDOL FARTE
TIOM B
OORORES TAT O MEIWSS IAEEETREVU
HUTHAR THAS THRKEAS Y  P.  AEFTT
"WAMPONETUTNEWA
ESIHE WFR.NED A
TEPLS.
UNSS
I
HESIEPARA
T
TKETTNE OGAYOALRBRMATVEWEHEVEGE
S AAR GORTHARWO F NDLPE TEENT C
ERF SOO
LKOWNO THI>> MRDVESEEIGT
LYY  HTR FTDO DNG IREREPYIM IEVM
HE TT
IS
OOEATVEODHIRWOKILORATE I ATHNS E
GRSW W>> WNS
S MPA EPHUEIRHATHZEOZ WSMANTARC
N ON TGCID HHEST AIROMNN ORITAC
S   P
EEE HA AME HASD.NESESEC"K IWO BI
HYS.STSERN,ENEIINLYIZ
NT KN